[Music]
welcome back you are watching the press
preview the first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
associate editor of the daily mirror
kevin mcguire and the broadcaster and
former conservative special adviser
anita watting they'll be with us from
now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
well the telegraph has an image of a
ukrainian woman standing in her garden
next to a grave russian soldiers said
was for her
the financial times leads on the latest
russian sanctions as western allies
target yet more banks
the times reports that the uk is set to
send armored vehicles to aid ukraine in
the fight against russia
the metro quotes the prime minister
saying he has absolutely no problem with
putting national insurance tax up
despite the rise in energy bills
the eye's front page focuses on
chancellor rishi sunak's wife stating
that she avoided tax through her
non-domicile status
the daily mirror also focuses on the
chancellor's wife
the guardian reports that the prime
minister's push for an increase in the
use of nuclear power has divided members
of his party and angered environmental
groups
the daily mail also leads on the prime
minister this time referring to him
saying that biological males shouldn't
compete in women's sports
and the sun reports more than 250 000
pounds worth of fuel has been stolen
from a royal navy warship
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
and tonight we're joined by associate
editor of the daily mirror kevin mcguire
and broadcaster and former conservative
special adviser anita barten welcome to
you both let's start with the
telegraph um and uh this just uh beggars
belief the a quote here i'll read from
the article what is this pit i asked
they said this is a graveyard for you
kevin
yeah the woman 69 uh in a in a town
outside of uh which is now being
liberated it's been some fantastic
reporting by british journalists and
indeed journalists around the world on
this war and that danielle sheridan from
the uh from the telegraph is going to
these areas and as the the russians
retreat and withdrawal uh
areas are giving up their grisly secrets
and uh this woman survived but of course
we know from uh butcher and others uh
other people didn't and
the rapes sexual violence used uh used
against the population war crimes people
have been bound executed uh civilians
it's absolutely horrific for this
this woman you just wonder how she's
going to to deal with it because yes
she's survived but surely the scars are
going to be there from what she
witnessed and experienced for the rest
of her life yeah and that that is the
thing anita isn't it that this is the
type of trauma you perhaps never get
over
completely and i think when we look at
what we are seeing even in places like
mario paul where there's evidence that
the russian soldiers are attempting to
cover up their trump crimes i sort of
dread to think about the other things
that we are not hearing about because um
those areas weren't we weren't able to
report um you know as kevin says there's
been some fantastic journalism here but
there are obviously periods where um
journalists weren't able to report
exactly what was happening so i think
that real um suspicion and grave alarm
uh what might have been going on in some
of these areas that were russian
dominated where the troops are pulling
back you know and that's really going to
be i think something that we're going to
be hearing much more about not just
tonight but in the coming weeks and
months yeah i mean it's it's really just
hard to imagine what these people are
going through but just in the article
when it says that now at night uh she
would have normally read or watched
television now she simply sits in the
dark and waits for morning to come i
mean just existing like that from day to
day it's just so telling those last few
words of that article and let's move on
to the ft and focusing on the sanctions
and the increased sanctions that have
been announced today kevin
yeah they've been built by the western
allies as the the harshest sanctions so
far targeting banks and also key members
of uh the regime putin's daughters maria
and katarina
sergi lavrov the foreign
minister's wife and daughter because the
way it works in russia is often they
put their their assets into family
members names to try and protect
themselves and
appear not to be as as rich from looting
russia as they they are
you've got to wonder why these sanctions
weren't imposed uh earlier
uh why they why they weren't tightened
uh sooner but they will have an impact
with an estimated uh 15 of the russian
economy about about to crash inflation
thought to go up to a similar
figure
but it's how long will putin try and uh
and sit it out because in some ways he's
calling it he's invaded um if he if he
pulled out now you'll be accepting a
massive defeat and when you look at the
the maps of where the russian action is
now you can see in the
south on the black sea coast and uh in
the uh in the east the donbass region
seems to be where he's uh going for his
uh territorial grab and of course the
poor the poor uh souls of mario paul uh
are in the middle of that and so you can
form a land corridor from russia to
crimea
uh anissa that has to be the question
are these further sanctions going to to
stop the war or could they potentially
push putin into a corner and we see more
outrageous acts more than we've already
seen well i think the the the us and the
west and actually i think the uk have
been very clear that the sanctions
are sort of essential but are not
necessarily sufficient to force putin to
think again
but the idea and i'm one i fully support
is that there has to be consequences for
this kind of action so we're talking
about you know the fifth round of
sanctions um you know kevin just talked
about some of the individuals that were
sanctioned but also spur bank um you
know bans on steel and and some of the
um the sort of core
products that russia often exports which
also generate significant revenue this
is really about sort of tightening the
noose in terms of putting pressure on
putin and making sure there are
consequences but i don't necessarily
think that now is the moment at which
he's suddenly going to feel backed into
a corner and therefore is going to think
again about his strategy but ultimately
part of what this this strategy is um it
is about kind of the people surrounding
vladimir putin that are enabling this
activity and perhaps helping them to see
that the ultimate consequences for the
russian economy and the russian people
and that putin is such a liability that
there is a moment now to pull back and
perhaps that this is the moment in which
they have to get rid of vladimir putin
so um you know this is an all nothing
strategy i guess but but fundamentally
it's not clear that the putin does take
a one-for-one response to um the the
british and the west putting pressure on
him in this way uh and and kevin uh this
feeds into uh our move away from
reliance on on energy from uh russia and
the world to move away and the prime
minister pushing for nuclear power but
but he's getting some backlash for that
yeah no absolutely um we in the uk get
very little uh power from from rochelle
unlike germany which gets about 40 of
its gas but nevertheless
excuse me it does impact on us but the
the energy security paper the prime
minister uh promised within days a month
ago is finally going to be published
tomorrow and the the guardians picking
up on a push for nuclear power and then
saying um that you know the tories and
green groups are all split because he
seems to be rolling back on onshore wind
uh turbines
a lot of nimbyism uh opposition to them
but yeah they're very very swift and
cheap uh electricity also gonna further
um develop the north sea
and fracking i couldn't see mentioned
there in the in the guardian report but
um because he made commitments that cop
26 in in glasgow for net zero and you
wonder how that will square with
developing more more north sea fields or
uh and
developing developing fracking but i
just wonder how much real detail there
is going to be
in this
paper if it doesn't set targets for
onshore wind
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me associate editor
of the daily mirror kevin mcguire and
broadcaster and former conservative
special adviser
boitang welcome back to you both um
let's have a look at the metro anita the
prime minister doesn't seem to have any
problem at all with
tax rises um but
lots of other people do
yes and so the metro's reporting on the
boris johnson's visit um to a hospital
today in which he underscored and
underlined the point that the increase
in national insurance that many of us
will be seeing for the first time in our
pay packets this month
is supposed to is a levy that's going to
generate 36 billion pounds for the nhs
help tackle the backlog and then
eventually get moved to be used um for
social care and i think it's pretty
interesting that the prime minister is
sort of leaning in
to um this tax hike which you know let's
not forget it wasn't in the 2019
manifesto in fact that manifesto ruled
out an increase in national insurance
and yet the prime minister has been
fairly front footed at this point in
saying well actually we think this is
the right thing to do
and it's really interesting if we go
back to september that moment when it
was announced that the government was
going to do this there was a lot of
conversation about the need to tackle
the nhs backlog and the focus was very
much on how else would you generate this
revenue but now at the point where
inflation is biting and the cost of
living is biting for many the
conversation is very much in the vein of
hang on you know we're seeing a lot of
tax increases is this the moment to
to go ahead with this and i think the
fact the government is stuck with this
knowing it may not necessarily read well
and not just in the metro but across
many papers i think it's indicative this
government's making a slightly tough
choice here and it's interesting to see
whether it pans out in the end yes kevin
and the prime minister says we've got to
do the difficult things we've got to
take the big decisions the right
decisions for this country are they the
right decisions kevin
yeah it's difficult uh difficult
decisions are always difficult for other
people he might have a problem with the
tax rises but i think a lot of people
who will be paying them uh will because
it's going to be the biggest drop in
living standards because falls since the
1950s and the uh tax burden's gone up
the highest rate since the uh end of the
1940s when there was still rationing
after the second world war so it's very
difficult i think to justify it as the
right thing
at this point when there's a cost of
living crisis but also this this idea is
going for the nhs well he's about to
give a large slice of it back uh boris
johnson and the chancellor of course
russia soon at more of him surely in
july when the national insurance
threshold is going to be raised by about
two and a half thousand to be in line
with uh income taxes over twelve and a
half thousand and then of course there's
a one p income tax uh cut being promised
in two years so the extra money is
almost all gonna be given
away so i think it was always just
branded uh as pain for health and social
care i just don't think it is
hypothecated in that way at all but uh
yes the government's saying that it will
go towards um
the health service which is much needed
we've just got time to talk about rishi
sunak's wife and her non-domiciled
status anita
yes um so this story is and there's been
a couple of stories about the
chancellor's wife in in recent weeks
ever since the spring statement um and
to this one is about her non-dom status
that means non-domiciled status and
that's about the fact that essentially
she is registered as not being a uk
citizen for tax purposes she is an
indian citizen um and you're not allowed
to have both indian and uk citizenship
but nevertheless i'm so sorry we're
going to have to to go in depth in this
story in the next hour um but thank you
very much both for the moment kevin and
anita we'll see you shortly on the other
side of the hour
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
i know we're all going to miss carol a
lot um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
do you think any of us will look back in
our lives and regret the things we
didn't buy
or the places we didn't go